this is the easiest rendering software
you can learn in 2022 and today I'm
going to teach you exactly what you need
to know in under 15 minutes what's going
on guys my name is David Thomas and I'm
a registered architect here in Western
Australia and I know that Bim software
is critically important but rendering
software is just as important to get you
the next client so today we're breaking
down everything you need to know to be
an expert in rendering in Twin motion
I'm simply going to start by pressing
the import button going across to open
and finding anything that I have
available to me in this instance I'm
going to be using a SketchUp file that
has been exported from archicad and
simply looks like this the SketchUp file
is my 3D model exported into multiple
parts so as you see it is the full 3d
model as we would have seen in archicad
now twin motion is very very simple and
for best results what we want to do is
actually use the best textures and
materials available so if we come across
the left hand side you say a small
little triangle and you'll see a series
of icons for different things it is very
self-explanatory what everything is but
instead of coming across the materials
in the top left we want to come to
quipsaw Mega scans we want to use these
materials and surfaces as much as we
possibly can throughout this entire
project wherever we possibly can to get
the best materials we can so as an
example if I came across the metal I
came across to bear and I found a
material that I personally liked let's
say this brushed aluminum looks good
I'll then simply download this material
to make it available to me wait a few
seconds for it to download drag and drop
that exactly on the material I'd like to
use it so in this instance the window
frames it would automatically adjust all
my settings at the bottom of the bar and
for this I want to make it a nice dark
black color so simply adjusting the
material if I fly in very close we're
going to see that texture that will
looking for we can scale it up and down
if we want to make it more aggressive
larger smaller we can increase the
reflectiveness so how shiny it is and
the colors as well so simply dragging
sliders up and down gives us what we're
actually looking for you can repeat the
same step for everything in the clipsal
maybe scans available Library however
the two things you probably won't find
in the surfaces is glass and neon light
but we're going to have to go up back to
the very start go to our materials press
on glass and select the glass that we
like significantly more so in this
instance I could pick mirrored glass
drag and drop reflective drag and drop
whatever my heart desired I also have to
go back scroll down to Neons and find a
neon color that I like introduce in to
my light strip here just like everything
else previously we have some sliding
scales up and down to adjust as we see
fit we also have more down the bottom if
we want to adjust the color of our
actual LED strip so it's better suited
now just like the materials what is very
important is plant selection neck but if
we come all the way back we have our
vegetation and Landscape at the top and
then we have a series of different
elements we have bushes shrubs flowers
Landscaping so all we need to really do
for any of our plant selections that we
like is scroll through find what we like
let's say we like this bush here we can
click on it once click on it again and
then repeatedly click or we can drag and
drop the same way we do with the actual
textures if we just want one at a time
these aren't enough for you again crypto
Mega scans has a variety of new 3D
plants that you can introduce into your
software in the latest version of twin
motion you also have sketchfab directly
integrated into twin motion so you can
simply search for whatever it is you're
looking for now what makes twin motion
so special is the 3D elements and the
Simplicity of it so like you see here we
have a big patch of grass that just
simply looks like grass it looks
terrible it's 2D it's flat so what we
want to do is actually come down to the
bottom to our context go to our
vegetation paint come back out of our
tree selection go to our grass select
the grass that we like the best and drag
it in to our palette down the bottom
next we want to select our brush reduce
the brush size to what we need and what
we're looking for and then simply paint
some grass in so without going into too
much complexity that is literally all
you have to do you can adjust your grass
density if you want it to be 100 grass
less Grass more grass and you can also
adjust to things like besides the actual
Blades of the grass the dryness The Tint
the stripe to make it look exactly how
you want it now if you've accidentally
clicked off that grass you can select it
once again to activate it and continue
painting like you would do originally as
well now you've got the basics of the
materials the textures the lighting as
well as the planting and grass next we
want to focus on the 3D Sky itself now
yeah yes twin motion has amazing Skies
but you really want to be using the sky
domes and you want to be using hdri
Skies so if we go into our noon cloudy
as an example we can select any one of
these clouds that we see fit let's pick
this second one download it drag and
drop it into your Sky allow it to
automatically create that 3D sky and
then you have a series of new toolbars
down the bottom that we can adjust so if
we rotate this guy we'll see the Shadows
adjust accordingly which is exactly what
we want to make sure it looks as
realistic as possible and then we can
also increase and decrease the sky's
actual intensity as well so for time
being I'm just going to leave it as four
and I'm just going to continue to rotate
this around to where I see the best
lighting is for me now if you don't like
that selection of the sky you can simply
select another one drag and drop it to
replace it and you can repeat this
process a million times until you find
the perfect sky for you now what really
makes a render realistic is the context
the character worked out and the actual
environment so after we finished
modeling all of our materials we've
fine-tuned all of our landscaping and
made everything perfect we also want to
make sure that we include Furniture
where we need it we want to include
curtains where we need it and we want to
include any of those finer details that
really make it look realistic so coming
back out of everything we can come back
into Quicks or Mega scans we can go to
our assets we can even come back into
our objects that are already pre-built
into archicad let's say we want to go
into home living room we want some
chairs we have an abundance of objects
available to us same as everything else
click drag drop as we see fit and place
them exactly where we want them to be
and exactly where we need them to be
when you finally accomplish that and put
everything into this scene exactly as
how you want it and exactly how you see
it if you're looking for anything
architecture related make sure you check
out the first link in the description
below
davidtomage.com has some fantastic
digital downloads that are going to save
you you an abundance of time as an
architect student or anybody in the
architecture profession the next thing
that makes a realistic render is your
camera and photography skills so when
you've completed everything to the way
you need you're going to come down to
this little media button down below
you're going to click on that go to our
image and create our first image it
doesn't matter what that first image is
aligned to because now we're actually
going to start moving around finding
that perfect camera angle adjusting for
this first of all and then we're going
to go into the more settings down below
and we're going to start playing with
the camera angles so starting off your
field of view is going to be about 90
degrees you want that to be anywhere
from 50 to 60 millimeters on a camera
lens because that is a nice clean prime
lens so if you simply adjust the field
as you see fit you'll find the perfect
angle that suits you in your environment
so in this instance I think 65
millimeters looks quite good for this
particular image I don't want to turn my
depth of field on I don't really care
care too much about power realism in
this instance I want to drop my
vignetting to zero and I can play around
with any other settings if I so choose
once that is adjusted you want to come
back to image one and you want to go to
your lighting format now what you'll
notice is exposure is zero zero but if
you come into more and turn exposure to
off you want to manually adjust that
exposure because the more you can
control the lighting the more you can
create the scene so by simply adjusting
the lighting to exactly how you want it
let's say 2.29 in this instance or
potentially even three we can simply
adjust it to where we see that picture
being perfect for us we don't want to
overexpose it especially if we're going
into Lightroom after we want to keep it
just underexposed a little bit last but
not least the most important most
critical element is when you come down
to the format picture button in the end
this is what it's going to do when it
exports the image so you want to make
sure it exports the image in the best
quality available to your computer by
default you have 2K 4 4K in later
versions you have 8K and 16k but what
you can do is Select 4K straight away
and that will give you twice the render
quality you would originally have by
default if your computer has more power
it has a good rendering card a good
graphics card then you can bump that up
to 8K 16k and you can get some really
stick images produced very quickly now
that's all well and good but before you
go too far you want to come back to your
image and you want to hit that refresh
button once again so that image is
completely saved the angles are set
ready to export now the last thing that
you have to do is come into export go to
image select your image and then press
the start export button when you have
completed all of those steps for every
single detail it may take you a
significant amount of time to actually
set everything up but the steps are
exactly the same throughout the entire
project so take your time go through the
materials Library go through the
planting Library find out exactly what
3D textures you need select and update
your camera angles perfectly for your
scene as well as your 3D sky and then go
ahead and Export the best 3D render your
computer is capable of to produce the
best renders possible in the shortest
amount of time anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed the video make
sure you check out the playlist to the
side of me if you love the video make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below but like always I'll see you
next Monday